in this video we'll take a look into how
assured workloads puts you in control
and provides transparency in the data
access because when it comes to your
data Google Cloud believes you should
always have the final say on who has
access I'm Carter Morgan and I'm excited
to show you a few ways Google Cloud's
data sovereignty protects your data no
matter where that data resides
Google Cloud provides customers with
easy to use capabilities to
comprehensively manage who has access to
what in your Cloud environment but
there's some limited circumstances where
Cloud administrators may need to access
customer content for instance us Cloud
providers are subject to Legal seizure
requests to provide customer data to
local and federal law enforcement
agencies to comply with the US Cloud app
in response to this concern from
customers around the globe Google Cloud
created assured workloads
assured workloads provide customers with
controls to restrict unauthorized access
to your data even in the event of a
legal seizure request as a quick
overview assured workloads is a product
that helps you implement and enforce
specific controls so you can confidently
run sensitive workloads on Google Cloud
this includes data residency data access
and Personnel access as the core
controls all of which we highlighted in
a previous video all organizations need
to do is to select the regulatory
framework they need to comply with and
Google Cloud will automatically deploy
the necessary controls to support your
regulatory requirements to provide the
highest level of protection transparency
and control to our customers we expanded
assure workloads to offer what we call
sovereignty controls
this video focuses on three key symmetry
controls and assured workloads Cloud
external key manager key access
justification and signed access
approvals
Cloud external key manager or ekm is a
Google cloud service that allows
customers to store and manage encryption
keys outside of Google Cloud when you
use cloud ekm externally managed keys
are never cached or stored within Google
cloud and you can choose on a per folder
basis where you want to use external
keys
the next Solomon tree control I want to
talk about is key access justifications
or KJ which is offered through assured
workloads this control adds a feel to
your Cloud ekm request that allows you
to view the system generated reason for
each request
you use kaj to set policies to
automatically approve or deny requests
for Keys based on the provided
justification
it's important to note Google cannot
modify the access controls or key access
justification policies for any external
Keys meaning that in the event of a
third party request for your data you
will be notified via request type and
can approve or deny it
the final sovereignty control assigned
access approval or SAA this control uses
the cryptographic signature of your
externally managed keys to sign access
requests that you approve this verifies
Integrity of the access approval that
allows access to your data
these savagery controls work together
with the Baseline controls of assured
workload to restrict access to your data
in the following ways data is restricted
to a region of the customer's choice
support Personnel access to customer
data is audited and can require customer
approval
Cloud ekm allows customers to hold and
manage their encryption keys outside of
Google Cloud
Kaja ensures the customers are in
control of when and why their data is
accessed and SAA helps prevent
unauthorized access approvals
simply put by using assured workloads
with sovereignty controls Google cannot
decrypt customer data without approval
which customers can withhold for any
reason
but enough talk let's see sovereignty
controls in action
let's see an example of ekm in action
in this demo we've already created keys
and set up assured workloads
in this demo we're using tablets but
there are many external key managers
that offer a similar feature set
we've also created a bigquery data set
that contains a table of mock data and
we've protected this data set with an
external key
we'll run the query and you can see the
results populate
a lot is happening behind the scenes to
make sure the data is secure because
this data set has been encrypted that
means there must have been a request to
the external key manager tell us
if we look at the logs you'll see that a
request was sent out and the reason for
the unwrap request was customer
initiated access
now let's examine how you as the
customer retain control over your data
in our ukm we can look at the endpoint
and can enable or disable it
[Music]
if we disable the endpoint and rerun our
bigquery query you'll see we get an
error saying the key URI is disabled
we can just as easily re-enable that
endpoint and access is allowed again
friends
[Music]
[Music]
let's see an example of setting up and
using kha in Dallas
now let's disable different types of
access using key access justifications
to show this we'll start by rotating the
key which will retire and replace the
existing key with a new one
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we'll still point the key towards the
same endpoint but when we go to our logs
we'll see a Google initiated system
operation took place
it's a different type of reason
these reasons can be used as access
justifications and can be enabled or
disabled individually
remember with Google Cloud you are the
ultimate Arbiter of access to your data
Google Cloud's data savagery controls
like Cloud ekm KJ and SAA ensure that
you have control and transparency
so there you have it if you want to
learn more visit cloud.google.com short
Dash workloads and stay tuned for more
episodes of assured workloads and
sovereignty updates to learn how to run
cloud workloads with compliance in mind
thanks for watching
[Music]